Was für ein wahnsinniger Tag im
Bereich KI. Wir hatten in den letzten
Tagen viele neue
Modellveröffentlichungen, große
Updates und es gibt viel zu besprechen.
Also, legen wir einfach direkt los. Und
wie versprochen bin ich mit meinem
dritten Upload des Tages zurück, um
über OpenAIs brandneue GPT-6 Soul und
GPT-6 Luna Modelle zu berichten. Anfang
des Monats stellte OpenAI die GPT-6
Astra-Serie als ihr bisher
leistungsstärkstes Modell vor. Doch
jetzt bringen sie die gleiche
Generation an Intelligenz in schnellere
und deutlich günstigere Modelle. Soul
und Luna bringen große Verbesserungen
beim Programmieren, bei der Faktenreue,
der Computernutzung und der
professionellen Arbeit, während sie
wesentlich effizienter laufen. Noch
besser ist, dass OpenAI die API-Preise
für Soul und Luna im Vergleich zum
Einführungspreis von GPT-5.1.6 um 50%
gesenkt hat, was Intelligenz auf
Spitzenniveau viel praktischer für die
großflächige Nutzung macht. Weiter
geht's: Ich habe bereits ein
ausführliches Testvideo zu Claude Opus
5.5 gemacht und ich empfehle sehr, es
euch über die Links in der
Beschreibung anzusehen. Aber mein Gott,
Leute, Anthropic hat ein
beeindruckendes Modell veröffentlicht
und ich glaube wirklich, dass es
derzeit das beste Modell der Welt ist.
Es ist etwas, das auf einem
außergewöhnlichen Niveau arbeitet. Es
performt bei vielen Aufgaben auf dem
Niveau von Claude 5.1, während es 40%
weniger kostet als Opus 5. Und ich habe
heute noch mehr Demos zu präsentieren.
Und das ist noch nicht alles. Claude
Haiku ist da, was für uns alle eine
Art Überraschung ist, da Anthropic
dies heute in ihrem Blogpost zu Opus
5.5 bestätigt hat, und es sieht auch
so aus, als könnten Claude Sonnet 5.5
und Haiku 5.5 in den kommenden Wochen
erscheinen. Wir haben auch Trump, der
über KI spricht, und dieser Typ will
anscheinend die Bezeichnung KI komplett
ändern und das ganze Branding neu
gestalten, und da gibt es viel zu
besprechen. Also, tauchen wir einfach
direkt in all das ein. Entschuldigt die
Zensur, Leute, aber mir ist aufgefallen
, dass viele von euch tatsächlich
nicht abonniert haben. Es würde uns
wirklich viel bedeuten, wenn ihr die
Benachrichtigungsglocke aktiviert und
dieses Video liked, da es uns wirklich
hilft, täglich mehr Videos zu
erstellen. Beginnen wir mit GPT-6 Soul
und Luna, den zwei neuen Modellen, die
entwickelt wurden, um GPT-6-
Level-Intelligenz ohne riesige Kosten
in den Alltag zu bringen. Und das ist
aufgrund der Preisstruktur wirklich
unglaublich. Hier erhält das GPT-5.6
Soul das GPT-6 Soul Upgrade, aber das
Verrückte ist, dass es zum halben
Preis gelistet ist. Es gibt einen
Nachlass von 50%. Das bedeutet, dass
Sie mit diesem Upgrade bereits
verschiedene Verbesserungen bei der
Programmierung, Sachlichkeit,
professionellen Arbeit, Computernutzung
und Ausrichtung erhalten, in schnellere
und deutlich günstigere Modelle. Die
GPT-6 Soul wird mit 2 $ für 1 Million
Eingabe-Token und 10 $ für 1 Million
Ausgabe-Token gelistet. Und beim
Übergang von der GPT-5.6 Luna zum GPT-
6 Luna-Upgrade sehen Sie, dass sich der
Preis halbiert hat: Er liegt jetzt bei
10 Cent für 1 Million Eingabe-Token
und 50 Cent für 1 Million
Ausgabe-Token, was einfach wahnsinnig
ist. Wenn es um professionelle Arbeit
geht, wird die GPT-5.6 Soul richtig
beeindruckend, denn auf der
Automatisierungs-Benchmark, die reale
Geschäftsprozesse über verschiedene
Apps hinweg testet, übertrifft die GPT
-6 Soul bei XHI-Aufwand tatsächlich
Claude Opus 5 bei maximalem Aufwand,
während sie nur 9%der Kosten pro
Aufgabe verursacht. Und Luna erhält
hier ebenfalls ein großes Upgrade,
denn bei hohem Aufwand verbessert sich
die GPT-6 Luna gegenüber ihrem
Vorgänger um 5,4 Prozentpunkte und
kostet dabei 58%weniger pro Aufgabe.
OpenAI macht diese Modelle also nicht
nur billiger, sondern holt auch
wesentlich mehr Leistung aus jedem
ausgegebenen Dollar heraus. Wenn Sie
die besten KI-Tools, Workflows und
Neuheiten vor allen anderen haben
wollen, abonnieren Sie meinen
kostenlosen Newsletter über den Link
in der Beschreibung unten, der komplett
gratis ist. Auf der
KI-Benchmark-Plattform „world of AI
“ liegt die GPT-3.6 Soul nun leicht
hinter GPT-3.6 Ashra. Aber das
Wichtigste ist, dass sie insgesamt auf
Platz drei rangiert, was ziemlich
beeindruckend ist. Und das natürlich
bei diesen lächerlichen
Preisstrukturen, bei denen das Modell
in Bezug auf seine Leistung sehr gut
abschneidet und gleichzeitig
unglaublich günstige Preise bietet.
Sie erhalten also mit diesem Modell das
Beste aus beiden Welten. Und dieses
Video wird Ihnen definitiv helfen,
dieses Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis zu
verstehen. Hier haben wir einen realen
Test der Opus 5.5 gegen die GPT-6 Soul.
Dabei werden beide Modelle von AIML API
anhand von vier One-Shot-3 D-Szenen
getestet. Dazu gehören ein animierter
Fischschwarm und einige andere Dinge,
wie ein Tsunami. Und natürlich werden
Sie visuell feststellen, dass Opus 5.5
in der Lage ist, bei all diesen Demos
ein detaillierteres Rendering zu
erstellen. Aber schauen Sie sich den
Kostenunterschied an. Für alle vier
Szenen kostete Opus 5.5 etwa 4,37 $,
was definitiv teuer ist. Im Vergleich
dazu kostet die Generierung aller vier
Szenen mit der GPT-6 Soul nur 34 Cent.
Offensichtlich ist die
Erzeugungsqualität bei Opus 5.5
unglaublich, aber GPT-6 Soul liegt gar
nicht so weit dahinter. Es ist immer
noch in der Lage, ziemlich gute
Ergebnisse zu liefern, und das
Hauptziel dieses Vergleichs ist, dass
Opus in diesem speziellen Test fast 13-
mal mehr gekostet hat. Opus 5.5 mag
zwar bei den visuellen Details die Nase
vorn haben, aber das
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis von GPT-6
Soul ist fast schon lächerlich,
besonders mit der neuen Preisstruktur,
die eingeführt wurde. Artificial
Analysis hat auch GPT-6 Soul und Luna
getestet, und die Ergebnisse sind
ziemlich interessant, da es nur einen
Punkt Unterschied zwischen dem GPT-5.6
Soul und diesem neuen GPT-6 Soul gibt.
Das ist recht interessant, da wir alle
erwartet hatten, dass dieses Modell
einen deutlichen Vorsprung gegenüber
dem GPT-5.6 Soul haben würde, was sich
aber so nicht gezeigt hat.
Offensichtlich ist die Preisstruktur
fast schon wahnsinnig, ebenso wie die
Kosteneffizienz und die Geschwindigkeit
. Ehrlich gesagt hatte ich bei der
Leistung etwas mehr erwartet, aber
vielleicht bin ich auch nur etwas zu
gierig, nachdem ich gesehen habe, was
mit Opus 5.5 möglich ist. Insgesamt
hat sich das Modell jedoch im Bereich
Programmierung definitiv verbessert.
Auch bei Luna gibt es in diesen
verschiedenen Kategorien einen
deutlichen Zuwachs. Und eine der
größten Verbesserungen, die ich
bisher bemerkt habe, ist die
Verringerung der Halluzinationen. Die
Halluzinationsrate von Soul ist von
verrückten 92%auf 60%gesunken,
während sie bei Luna von 93%auf 77%
zurückgegangen ist. Und das ist
einfach bemerkenswert. Ich habe GPT-6
Soul und Luna natürlich einem strengen
Test mit meiner Prompt-Bibliothek
unterzogen, auf die Sie über die Links
in der Beschreibung unten zugreifen
können. Man kann viele dieser
Funktionen sogar kostenlos nutzen, aber
was mir bei meinen Tests aufgefallen
ist, ist, dass man in vielen dieser
Fälle praktisch die gleichen
Ergebnisse wie mit Opus 5.5 erhält.
Warum also nicht einfach dieses neue
Luna-oder Soul-Modell verwenden, das im
Vergleich zu Opus 5.5 deutlich
günstiger ist, aber praktisch die
gleiche Art von Ausgabe liefert? Viele
dieser verschiedenen Generationen sind
einfach unglaublich, und man fragt sich
, ob man immer Opus 5.5 verwenden
sollte oder ob man aufgrund der
Kosteneffizienz und Geschwindigkeit
nicht lieber ein Modell wie Soul als
Hauptinstrument einsetzen sollte, um
Aufgaben zu erledigen? Denn viele der
Generationen, die ich gerade sehe,
zeigen einfach, wie unglaublich das GPT
-6 Soul-Modell sowie das Luna-Modell
sind, da insbesondere beim Front-End
der Designgeschmack dieses Modells
wirklich bemerkenswert ist. Und ich
werde ein paar weitere Generationen
präsentieren, die Sie dazu anregen
werden, darüber nachzudenken, was Sie
tatsächlich mit diesem Modell
anstellen können. Und mit dieser
Veröffentlichung hat Tibo auch einen
Reset angekündigt, der gespeichert ist
und den Sie jederzeit in den
Einstellungen einfordern können. Das
ist also ein zusätzlicher Vorteil bei
dieser Modellveröffentlichung. Aber
natürlich möchte ich ehrlich zu Ihnen
sein. Das GPT-6 Whole liegt definitiv
weit hinter diesem neuen Opus 5.5-
Modell zurück. Sogar beim GPT-6 Astra
gibt es jetzt definitiv eine klare
Lücke, und das nicht nur in ein paar
Bereichen. Es erstreckt sich über
mehrere Bereiche, was irgendwie
verrückt ist, da Opus 5.5 einen
ziemlich massiven Vorteil in vielen
verschiedenen Bereichen hat, von der
Programmierung bis zur Computernutzung
sowie dem Allgemeinwissen. Anhand
dieses Vergleichs als Beispiel: Hier
wurde angefordert, eine New York City
in 3.js zu erstellen, also die Skyline
und die Stadt insgesamt mit Gebäuden
und verschiedenen Arten von Komponenten
. Und hier wurde angefordert, die
Dächer, die Taxis, die Brooklyn Bridge
, den Central Park und all diese
interaktiven 3 D-Umgebungen mit diesem
Prompt vollständig auszuprogrammieren.
GPT-6 Soul hingegen hat natürlich eine
der besseren Generationen für diesen
Prompt produziert, aber man sieht, dass
das Modell nur ein statisches Bild
ausgeben konnte. Man konnte die Kamera
nicht wirklich bewegen. Sie haben den
Code nicht wirklich generiert. Es
enthielt nicht einmal eine richtige
Render-Schleife. Also hat es die Szene
einfach nur einmal gerendert und dann
gestoppt. Aber das Opus 5.5 ging weit
darüber hinaus. Es hat alles aufgebaut
. Alle Texturen, Shader und
Beleuchtungen wurden dieser 3
D-Umgebung zugewiesen. Es zeigt also
nur, dass das Opus 1.5 derzeit einen
klaren Vorsprung vor jedem anderen
Modell hat. Aber andererseits, Leute,
wenn es darum geht, Prompts wirklich
detailliert auszuarbeiten, oder besser
gesagt, wenn man sie richtig anspricht,
wie in diesem Fall, wo ich es gebeten
habe, einen Mac-Klon oder ein
browserbasiertes Mac-Betriebssystem mit
der Fähigkeit zur Interaktion mit dem
Telefon zu erstellen, hat es mit diesem
Ergebnis ziemlich gute Arbeit geleistet
. Es hat all diese Komponenten wie den
Kalender erstellt, das iOS wurde
vollständig etabliert. Sie haben sogar
den Sperrbildschirm, und das ist
einfach der Wahnsinn, weil man all
diese coolen Komponenten hat, die für
das MacBook programmiert wurden und nun
auf iOS übertragen wurden. Das ist
etwas, das ich bisher bei keinem Modell
gesehen habe, denn wann immer wir die
Erstellung eines browserbasierten
Prompts angefordert haben, wurden nicht
alle diese Elemente tatsächlich
programmiert. Dies ist eine
Bildschirm-Spiegelungs-App, die
ausgegeben wurde und alle Apps auf
Ihrem MacBook sowie Ihre iOS-Apple-App
oder Ihr Mobilgerät anzeigt. Und hier
wurden sogar all diese verschiedenen
einzelnen Anwendungssymbole als SVG
programmiert. Nun, eine Sache ist mir
aufgefallen: Ich kann die eigentlichen
Ordner oder Anwendungen nicht
verschieben, was definitiv ein
ziemlicher Nachteil ist. Ich müsste
darum bitten, das zu verbessern, aber
abgesehen davon gibt es viele dieser
coolen Dinge, die hinzugefügt wurden.
Offensichtlich sind die Hyperlinks und
die Anwendungen alle vollständig
programmiert. Es gibt sogar einen
Musikplayer, der zu funktionieren
scheint, was gut ist. Er spielt zwar
keine besonders gute Musik ab, aber
abgesehen davon scheint alles andere zu
funktionieren. Insgesamt liebe ich die
Generierungsqualität dieses Modells.
Es erfordert lediglich, dass man viel
mehr Details eingibt, um das zu
bekommen, wonach man sucht. Und apropos
Modellveröffentlichungen: Anthropic
hat heute auch Claude Opus 5.5
herausgebracht. Dies ist das erste
Modell der Claude 5.5-Familie und es
ist ein wirklich unglaubliches Modell.
Es ist derzeit das am besten bewertete
Modell und bietet bei fast jeder
Aufgabe ein ähnliches oder sogar
besseres Leistungsniveau als Fable 5.1,
während es 40%weniger kostet als Opus
5. Genau wie bei OpenAI liegt der Fokus
derzeit also nicht darauf, die Modelle
intelligenter zu machen. Es geht darum,
Leistung auf Spitzenniveau zu deutlich
geringeren Kosten zu liefern. Oh, und
falls Sie es noch nicht wussten: Sie
bieten auch einen kostenlosen Reset des
Rate Limits an. Sie können über die
Einstellungen darauf zugreifen, und ich
glaube, es läuft am 22. Oktober ab,
also lösen Sie es ein, wann immer Sie
es brauchen. Ich habe bereits mein
ausführliches Video zu Opus 5.5
gemacht, daher empfehle ich Ihnen
dringend, es sich anzusehen. Aber hier
werden wir uns ein paar neue Beispiele
dafür ansehen, was Opus 5.5 ausgeben
kann, und es ist einfach irre, weil man
den Detailgrad im Vergleich zu etwas
wie GPT Astra wirklich erkennen kann.
Hier wurde nämlich verlangt, eine
Simulation eines Nachtzugs zu erstellen
, der durch die Landschaft fährt–
oder nicht einmal durch die Landschaft.
Das ist nicht einmal die Landschaft.
Was rede ich da überhaupt? Das ist der
Norden. Sagen wir, Alaska, vielleicht.
Dies ist eine Simulation eines Zuges,
der durch die Gleise in dieser
bestimmten Region fährt, und man kann
den Detailgrad bei der Beleuchtung
sowie bei den Kamerawinkeln sehen, die
dem Zug folgen, sowie viele andere
Dinge wie die Umgebung selbst, die
vollständig in 3.js programmiert ist.
Das zeigt einfach, dass es jetzt
wirklich eine Lücke zu OpenAI gibt,
die zwar gute Arbeit bei dieser
Generierung leisten, aber nicht auf dem
Qualitätsniveau von Opus 1.5. Ich habe
meine Minecraft-Demo heute bereits im
Video gezeigt, aber das ist eine
bessere Generierung, die Shader in
diese Aufgabe integriert hat, um ein
Sandbox-Spiel wie das ursprüngliche
Minecraft zu erschaffen. Es ist einfach
völlig verrückt, dass ein KI-Modell
diesen kompletten Sandbox-Spiel-Klon
mit all seinen Kernkomponenten erstellt
hat, und nicht nur das, sondern auch
Shader hinzugefügt hat, was das
gesamte Gameplay viel besser aussehen
lässt. Denn das ist einfach irre, weil
Opus 1.5 für 1 Stunde und 37 Minuten
bei maximaler Anstrengung lief und dies
das Ergebnis mit offensichtlich
beeindruckender Beleuchtung, Shadern,
Texturen und Optik war. Und es sieht in
vielen Bereichen offensichtlich viel
besser aus als das ursprüngliche
Minecraft. Hier ist ein weiteres
Beispiel, bei dem es mit 3.js
überzeugt, um einen Spider-Man-Klon zu
erstellen. Das ist ein vollständiger
Klon wie das ursprüngliche Spider-Man:
Miles Morales-Spiel, und das hat es
tatsächlich mit mittlerem Aufwand
geschafft, nicht einmal mit maximalem.
Man erhält also diese Art von Ausgabe
mit diesem mittleren Reasoning-Level,
und es hat offensichtlich alle
Kernkomponenten hinzugefügt, die man
tatsächlich aus dem Originalspiel
kannte, von den Texturen bis zu den
Animationen sowie die
Schwung-Komponente oder die
Schwingbewegung, die man im
Originalspiel hat. Es ist also einfach
verrückt, dass wir an einem Punkt
angelangt sind, an dem ein KI-Modell
nicht nur das Frontend für
verschiedene Landingpages ausgeben kann
, sondern jetzt sogar komplette Spiele
für einen programmieren kann, was
einfach wahnsinnig ist. Für mich ist
das einfach schwer zu glauben. Erinnert
ihr euch an Elden Ring? Ich glaube, so
hieß das Spiel. Äh, Elden Ring, ich
habe es gespielt. Und es ist im Grunde
ein Teil der Dark-Souls-Reihe, und hier
hat jemand tatsächlich Opus 5.5 mit
maximaler Argumentationstiefe gebeten,
ein Spiel im Stil von Elden Ring zu
erstellen, und es ist einfach
unglaublich, denn das übertrifft meine
Erwartungen bei weitem, da es einen
kompletten Klon erstellt hat, der
tatsächlich fantastisch aussieht. Es
sieht dem ursprünglichen
Elden-Ring-Spiel ziemlich ähnlich. Es
fügt Texturen hinzu, sogar einen
Bosskampf, was einfach verrückt ist.
An diesem Punkt könnte man jedes
beliebige KI-Modell bitten, eine Art
Klon eines Spiels zu erstellen, aber
genau hier geht Opus 5.5 noch einen
Schritt weiter. Es ist in der Lage, die
visuelle Qualität des Originalspiels
präzise zu treffen, indem es diese
Aspekte sowie die Texturen klont und
dann eine ausgefeilte interaktive
Erfahrung aufbaut, die das
Originalspiel nachahmt. Sei es, dass
das Wissen über das Originalspiel in
den Klon implementiert wird oder dass
der Fokus darauf liegt, das Projekt
stärker auf den Kernprinzipien des
Originalspiels aufzubauen, was man bei
keinem anderen Modell bisher gesehen
hat. Jedes Modell, das man bittet,
einen solchen Klon zu erstellen, würde
zwar eine grundlegende Struktur dessen
generieren, wonach man sucht, aber es
bietet nicht die gleiche Tiefe oder die
Implementierung der Kernkonzepte des
Originalspiels. Während Opus 1.5 an
einen Punkt gelangt, an dem es genau
das aufgrund seines Intelligenzniveaus
leisten kann. Wenn euch dieses Video
gefällt und ihr den Kanal
unterstützen möchtet, könnt ihr eine
Spende über die „Super Thanks“-
Option unten in Erwägung ziehen oder
unserem privaten Discord beitreten, wo
ihr monatlich kostenlosen Zugriff auf
verschiedene Abonnements für KI-Tools,
tägliche KI-Nachrichten, exklusive
Inhalte und vieles mehr erhaltet. Wie
dem auch sei, Opus 5.5 ist ein
unglaubliches neues Modell als Teil der
neuen Claude-5.5-Familie, und wo wir
gerade von dieser neuen Familie
sprechen: Es sieht so aus, als würde
Anthropic endlich Claude Haiku
zurückbringen, und es ist definitiv am
Leben, denn Anthropic hat heute
offiziell bestätigt, dass Claude
Sonnet 5.5 sowie Haiku 5.5 in den
kommenden Wochen erscheinen werden, und
beide Modelle werden voraussichtlich
viele der Verbesserungen mitbringen,
die wir bei Opus 5.5 sehen, was sehr
interessant ist. Und wenn wir eine
ähnliche Leistung, Effizienz und
Sicherheit bei diesen neuen Modellen
erhalten, wird das definitiv
bemerkenswert sein und tatsächlich das
nachahmen, was wir bei den GPT-6-Soul-
sowie Luna-Modellen gesehen haben. Als
Nächstes von Alibaba: Es sieht so aus,
als würde die Qwen-Modellreihe bald
schnell voranschreiten. Wie wir bereits
in anderen Videos auf der
Apsara-Konferenz erwähnt haben,
bereiten sie die Veröffentlichung der
Qwen-4-Modellreihe vor, und jetzt liegt
uns eine Liste der Modelle vor, die
Alibaba herausbringen wird. Dazu
gehört das Qwen 4 Max, das an der
Spitze der Liste stehen wird. Wir haben
das Qwen 4 Plus sowie das Qwen 4 Flash.
Und jetzt bitte einen Trommelwirbel,
denn das Qwen 4 27B kommt auf uns zu.
Ich bin wirklich gespannt, was sie mit
diesem Modell veröffentlichen werden,
denn wir werden ein lokales Modell
erhalten, das praktisch auf Augenhöhe
mit den aktuellen Spitzenmodellen ist,
was unglaublich wäre. Noch verrückter
ist jedoch, dass Qwen anscheinend den
nächsten Schritt plant. Sie planen,
mit zukünftigen Qwen 4.5-und Qwen 5-
Modellen aggressiv weiter zu skalieren
und möglicherweise irgendwo zwischen 5
und 10 Billionen Parameter zu erreichen
. Und wenn das passiert, sprechen wir
von einem absolut massiven Sprung in
Bezug auf die Skalierung für die
Qwen-Familie. Als Nächstes: Die HY
Image 3.5 Preview ist offiziell live.
Sie stammt von Tencent und bringt ein
weiteres großes Upgrade für Tencents
Bilderstellungs-Reihe. Laut dem Team
liefert es eine um 30%höhere
Gewinnrate bei menschlichen Bewertungen
im Vergleich zu HY Image 3.0, mit
Verbesserungen bei der Konsistenz und
Unterstützung für Text-zu-Bild sowie
Bild-zu-Bild. Dies geschieht bei
Generierungen mit einer Auflösung von
bis zu 2K, was irgendwie wahnsinnig ist
. Doch die Preisgestaltung könnte der
interessanteste Teil dieser neuen
Modellveröffentlichung sein. Über
Tencent Cloud kostet es nur 2 Cent pro
generiertem Bild, und Referenzbilder
werden tatsächlich nicht berechnet.
Dies ist also ein weiteres Bildmodell,
das sowohl Qualität als auch
Kosteneffizienz vorantreibt, und ich
bin definitiv gespannt, wie es sich im
Vergleich zu anderen Top-Bildmodellen
schlägt. Zuletzt mein Junge Trump.
Eigentlich weiß ich gar nicht, ob er
mein Junge ist, weil dieser Typ mich
immer fertig macht, besonders an der
Börse. Aber dieser Trump wollte
anscheinend ändern, was wir in Bezug
auf die Namensgebung als KI bezeichnen.
Anfangs argumentierte er, der Begriff
Künstliche Intelligenz sei ungenau,
und bat die Leute, zwischen Superior
Intelligence, Extreme Intelligence und
Supreme Intelligence abzustimmen.
Supreme wurde schließlich gestrichen,
und in seiner letzten X-Umfrage gewann
Superior Intelligence knapp mit 52%von
184.000 Stimmen. Und Trump schlug eine
etwas andere Richtung ein, als er am
22. September vor der UN sprechen
sollte. Er sagte, er wolle, dass die
US-Regierung KI als Superintelligenz
oder SI bezeichnet, mit dem Argument,
das Wort künstlich lasse die
Technologie unecht klingen. Und er
sagte, US-Regierungsdokumente würden
diese neue Terminologie in Zukunft
verwenden. Also, anscheinend,
willkommen im Zeitalter der SI. Das
bedeutet, ich muss meinen Kanalnamen
ändern. World of SI jetzt. Aber das
war es auch schon, Leute. Ich bin
definitiv müde, also werde ich jetzt
schlafen gehen. Aber schaut euch auf
jeden Fall die World of AI
School-Community an. Werft einen Blick
auf den World of AI-Benchmark. Und
falls ihr es noch nicht getan habt,
schaut euch unbedingt den zweiten Kanal
an. Tretet unserem Newsletter und
Discord bei, folgt mir auf Twitter. Und
zu guter Letzt: Abonniert den Kanal,
aktiviert die Benachrichtigungsglocke,
gebt diesem Video ein Like und schaut
euch bitte unsere früheren Videos an,
damit ihr über alles, was in der Welt
der KI passiert, auf dem Laufenden
bleibt. Aber mit diesem Gedanken, Leute
, habt einen großartigen Tag,
verbreitet Positivität und wir sehen
uns bald wieder. Macht’s gut, Leute.